We were experimenting with psychedelics as
much as we were playing music.
It's a philosophy of leaving yourself open
to possibility
and leaving yourself open to magic.
The Acid Test experience really formed the
band as a group mind.
The Grateful Dead.
The band forged during the acid tests of the
1960s,
that grew to become one of the most popular live
acts in American history,
is the subject of a new four hour film by
academy award nominated director
Amir Bar-Lev.
There's sex, drugs, rock and roll.
But also a kind of a different attitude towards
fame
and towards the relationship with fans,
that I think people, whether you like the
band or not,
are going to find informative and interesting.
You know, when I was a teenager picking from
the palette of cultural options out there
and, you know,
picking from stuff that MTV wanted to serve
me, or exploring the Grateful Dead,
the Grateful Dead represented a kind of a
high standard of honest music.
You know?
That I changed my life and my attitude towards
music and I know I'm not alone.
If you were in the audience you were included
in the experience.
We should have known something was coming,
when there were more people outside the show,
than there were inside.
I'm a lefty, right. So when I hear that Tucker
Carlson and Anne Coulter
call themselves Deadheads,
my natural response is to say 'No, they don't
get it.'
But that's, I think, wrong.
That's the wrong attitude that I have.
And if you look at what the Grateful Dead
were about, it was a radical inclusivity,
and there was no one way to be a Deadhead,
everybody was welcome:
Motorcyclists, newbies, gatecrashers, psycho
right-wingers.
I think they are the musical statue of liberty,
you know?
Because they invited everybody to participate,
not just to watch, to participate.
There was this strong belief that it be leaderless.
Who was in charge?
Well I'm so glad you asked that.
There were times when I was in charge, times
when Jerry was in charge,
you had a truck that had a blown carburetor,
that carburetor was the boss.
I think Jerry was radically anti-authoritarian
and all the guys are, in the band.
And so, you know, when people began to elect
them to be authorities,
they had a natural concern and skepticism
around that.
And I think that's healthy.
I wish more people in power were concerned
about power and wielding power.
You know, and I think that's what gave the
Grateful Dead it's longevity.
It was never about one person or seven people.
It was something more pluralistic.
The band had a healthy skepticism
around a kind of top-down authoritarian approach to community.
The Grateful Dead famously let people tape
their music and, you know,
keep bootlegs of them for free.
And I think, you know, that was part and parcel
of an ethos with the Grateful Dead,
that, you know, that you trust people.
That made us feel like we were participating
in something and that we were trustworthy.
And you know, of course that drew more people
to them.
It was very American because it, you know,
you weren't being told what to do,
you were being asked to do the right thing
and being made responsible for your own actions.
It's not up to us to define the Grateful Dead.
It's a living, breathing thing.
I think that's one of the parts of it's magic.
Not defining it is that it becomes everything.
The Grateful Dead had nothing to do with creating
a community around them.
They just made space for it, you know?
They made space by not taking up all the room
with themselves and their own egos.
That's like so refreshing and missing from
popular culture today.
They, you know, there's this great line in the film
where Jerry says:
'What I loved about the acid test is people
weren't there to see us.'
Do you think, you know, would you ever hear
a rock star say:
'the best thing about those early shows is
we weren't the center of attention.'
It set a tone that, you know, is why they're
still here today.